The Alchemist
by Paulo qualo
book summary
Santiago a young and adventurous
Andalusian Shepherd is troubled by a
recurring dream
he has the dream every time he sleeps
under a sycamore tree that grows out of
the ruins of a church
in the dream a child tells him to seek
treasure at the foot of the Egyptian
pyramids
to interpret the dream Santiago consults
a Gypsy Woman and to his surprise she
tells him to go to Egypt
a strange magical old man named
Melchizedek who claims to be the king of
Salem Echoes the gypsy's advice and
tells Santiago that it is his personal
Legend to Journey to the pyramids
Melchizedek convinces Santiago to sell
his flock and set off to Tangier
when Santiago arrives in tenure a thief
robs him forcing him to find work with a
local Crystal Merchant
the conservative and kind Merchant
teaches Santiago various lessons and in
return Santiago encourages the merchant
to take risks with his business
the risks pays off and Santiago becomes
a rich man within a year
Santiago decides to cash in his earnings
and continue pursuing his personal
Legend to find treasure at the pyramids
he joins a caravan crossing the Sahara
Desert toward Egypt and meets an
Englishman who is studying to become an
alchemist
he learns a lot from the Englishmen
during the journey
for one he learns that the secret of
alchemy is written on a stone called The
Emerald Tablet
the ultimate creation of alchemy is the
Masterwork which consists of a solid
called the Philosopher's Stone that can
turn lead to gold and a liquid called
The Elixir of life that can cure all
ills
Santiago learns the Englishman is
traveling with the Caravan to the
Saharan Oasis of al-fayam where a
powerful 200 year old Alchemist resides
the Englishman plans to ask The
Alchemist The Secret of his trade
as it turns out the Caravan must make an
extended stop in al-fayim in order to
avoid increasingly violent Tribal wars
taking place in the desert
there Santiago falls in love with Fatima
who lives at the Oasis
during a walk in the desert Santiago
witnesses an omen that portends an
attack on the historically neutral Oasis
he warns the tribal Chieftains of the
attack and as a result al-fam
successfully defends itself against the
assault
The Alchemist gets word of Santiago's
vision and invites Santiago on a trip
into the desert during which he teaches
Santiago about the importance of
listening to his heart and pursuing his
personal Legend
he convinces Santiago to leave Fatima
and the Caravan for the time to finish
his journey to the pyramids and he
offers to accompany Santiago on the next
leg of his trip
while The Alchemist and Santiago
continue through the desert The
Alchemist shares much of his wisdom
about the soul of the world
they are mere days away from the
pyramids when a tribe of Arab soldiers
captures them
in exchange for his life and the life of
Santiago The Alchemist hands over to the
tribe all of Santiago's money and tells
the soldiers that Santiago is a powerful
Alchemist who will turn into wind within
three days
Santiago feels alarmed because he has no
idea how to turn into the wind and over
the next three days he contemplates the
desert
on the third day he communicates with
the wind and the Sun and coaxes them to
help him create a tremendous sandstorm
he prays to the hand that wrote All and
at the height of the storm he disappears
he reappears on the other side of the
camp and the tribesmen awed by the power
of the storm and by Santiago's ability
let him and The Alchemist go free
The Alchemist continues to travel with
Santiago as far as a Coptic Monastery
several hours from the pyramids
there he demonstrates to Santiago his
ability to turn lead into gold using the
Philosopher's Stone
he gives Santiago gold and sends him off
Santiago begins digging for the treasure
at the foot of the pyramids but two men
accost him and beat him
when Santiago speaks to them about his
dream Vision they conclude he have no
money and let him live
before leaving one of the men tries to
illustrate the worthlessness of Dreams
by telling Santiago about his own dream
it concerns a treasure buried in an
abandoned church in Spain where a
sycamore tree grows
the church is the same one in which
Santiago had his original Dream and he
finally understands where his treasure
is
he returns to Spain to find a chest of
jewels and gold buried under the tree
and plans to return with it to al-fayam
where he will reunite with Fatima
the end